[Musica]
perché la fa
come successo a
[Musica]
ve lo portate la tonnellata di cibo qui
la ferita così via severi finito c'è un
grosso problema nel piano di sopra c'è
qualcuno che ti somiglia nella vasca da
bagno e una sorta di sirena cattiva la
siriana cattiva ora capisco qua nella
piscina ci sono delle creature strane
ogni tanto spuntano fuori e mi stavano
mordendola coda credo che vogliano
mangiarmi dobbiamo sbrigarci devo subito
nasconderti fuori dall'acqua perché sono
sicuro che sta arrivando non puoi
nascondermi fuori dall'acqua e io non
posso far vivere fuori dalla quanto
contenere la coda a bagno
o un'idea ci porterà fuori dall'acqua ma
ti terrò fuori solo lo stretto
necessario per fare in modo che la coda
non si sia chi troppo e mi devo occupare
velocemente della sirena cattiva per
sistemarla per sempre hai già un piano
per eliminarlo spero di sì qualcuno che
si avvicina preghiamo cinque le famiglie
d'acqua ok qui all'ombra non dovrebbe
essere male beni sicuro che questo è un
buon nascondiglio non sono molto
nascosta l'importante è che se all'ombra
così tanti secche rai poi le tenderemmo
una trappola
non ti preoccupare vedrai un piano in
serbo per lei va bene mi fido del tuo
piano ma ricordati di sbrigarsi perché
non posso stare troppo tempo fuori
dall'acqua anche se sono l'ombra
però nel frattempo dimmi qual è il tuo
piano ok allora innanzitutto di
richiamare la sirena qua qui vicino a te
e poi al resto ci penserò io occupare
chiamarla qui io non dovrei nascondermi
che dovrei chiamarla qui non ha senso
questa volta non si può occupare un
piano geniale e va bene io la chiamo ma
tieniti pronto ok
marino non sta più facendo la guardia
alla sirena cattiva quindi vuol dire che
sta arrivato qui
sirena cattiva
mourinho
sono qua stai cercando me è vero sono
qua
vieni pure non ho paura di te
[Musica]
ci mette ad arrivare
eccolo
capitale dice che una mia sosia secondo
me non mi sono
pure na buren a
che punto
lì alle gambe allora non è una sirena
perché tale ha detto che una sirena se
alle gambe
iniqua che un qualcosa per te
che cosa ha in mente deve stare molto
attento o una conchiglia magica
perché
maledetta morena mercati questo
ciò che si sa se non ho mai usato
spingermi in acqua
con l'acqua che trasforma del silena
adesso un piano malefico
resta pure lì murena tanto non puoi
camminare hai la coda
adesso che l'ho trasformata in sirena
buttandole dell'acqua addosso posso
finalmente intrappolarla con il mio dono
gigante
murena sto arrivando
affatto
non
è troppo di un altezza non ci credo
gravissimo vitale
mandami
piano geniale
la coda
[Musica]
bravissimo se sì siete eliminarli
dov'è finita è scomparsa c'è più niente
nella piscina si è volatilizzata
ma non ci sono neanche gli squaletti più
castrano moretti meccanici
vabbè l'importante che se volete
sconfiggere il nemico
e ora possiamo andare a mangiare
tranquillamente
ciao
[Musica]